good morning John about 15 years ago I
for the first time and begrudgingly took
the myers-briggs personality test the
idea of that specific personality test
is to put you into one of two groups in
four different categories the most
famous one being the first one are you
an introvert or an extrovert are you an
i or an is also how you gather
information as it's sensing or intuition
how you make decisions thinking or
feeling and finally do you prefer to
like make judgment or gather more
information through perceiving or
prospecting turn different piece and it
changes so you might be like an intp or
an IAS FJ at that time in my life I had
decided to hate personality tests like
what a great deal of my understanding of
myself was like you can't put this in a
box this is why I was extremely pleased
when my myers-briggs personality type
came back as X n X P so for introvert
extrovert they couldn't classify me I
was right in the middle and for thinking
they're feeling also right in the middle
so yeah you can't put a college Hank in
a box take that test try to tell me that
I am like anyone else to be fair to the
test
what's pretty weird like I loved to like
go to parties and dance and like have
people looking at me but mostly because
of how scary that was I love it in the
way like that a parachuter loves jumping
out of a plane like it's an extreme
sport but wanting to not be classifiable
it's not why I dislike personality tests
now I have a different reason and it's
much more mild because I think it's
extremely valuable to take some time for
self-reflection and to assess ourselves
and to understand ourselves and see what
maybe are the right paths forward for
who we are right now but I also worry
that the idea of a personality test
leads to the belief that we are what we
are and we will never be anything else I
just took another myers-briggs
personality test at 16 something's calm
and as I was taking the test it became
very clear to me that I've changed a lot
and that like if I answered these
questions as five years ago Hank I would
be answering them differently I am much
more of a planner where I used to be an
improviser and part of that's having a
child but part of that's having like a
team of 15 people that are not ready for
me to email them at midnight to be like
tomorrow we're gonna do this new thing
that can be frustrating for an employee
it turns out and it turns out that I
actually like working that way it's a
little less scary and it is
become the default way I operate and
also now I'm not in the middle of
introvert/extrovert I am way over in the
extrovert side and anybody who knows me
will tell you that so this is the time
of year when people might be setting
goals for how they want to behave or how
they want things to go in 2018 and what
that means is changing behavior and that
is freaking hard because we emphasize
these neural pathways ways that we act
things we do with our hands how we
interact with other people what we give
value to all those neural pathways get
more and more structured and changing
them gets more difficult and I want to
make the case that it really doesn't
help if we believe that we were born to
only ever be one way ever we change our
our based on situations and we change a
decade to decade if there's something
very simple about feeling like you'll
never change and about taking a test and
knowing who you are but we're not that
simple I think it's a disservice to the
complexity of you absolutely find ways
to live that work for you and people who
appreciate you for the way you are but
also know that if you want to change you
can and even if you don't you probably
will so if you have a moment I have an
exercise can you write down in the
comments for all of us to read something
that you changed about yourself it could
be something simple like you changed how
you write a so it can be more
complicated like you decided to be the
kind of person who listens more and
talks less I mean if there's somebody
here who needs to take that advice I
don't know and if you want you could
also share some of the ways that you
hope to maybe change in the future
because you were not carved in stone the
day you were born you are molding
yourself out of clay and if you don't
keep it moving it's gonna harden up John
I'll see you on Tuesday
if you ever want to learn more about
this stuff with a great deal more rigor
than was in this video I'll check out
our channel scishow psych it's all about
the science of psychology